je vais vous parler de l' esclavage
abois beauvue pas augusto logé au début
des années 1840 puisque il est présent
ici entre la fin 2008 139 et janvier
1846 donc on voit bien c'est vraiment
les années le premier le premier
demi-siècle le premier pendant les cinq
premières années des années 1840 qu'il
est là 1840 à 10 845
et donc
jeunesse les pans entiers imprimeur à
laval
décide de publier en 1845 un ouvrage
titré loisirs nouvelle le bois mon
composé de deux parties la première est
la plus longue elle représente 62 % de
l'ensemble et rassemble cinq nouvelles
je vous donne les titres de ces
nouvelles des états le créole bras de
fer saint félix la cabem d'oscar la
valide gj de girofliers de son ami
augusto loger né le 15 janvier 1813 à
entrammes qui est le chef lieu du
département de le pardon quelques pas
manquer la commune une commune du
département de la mayenne donc il est né
en tram et la rési d aller le bourdon
2839 al janvier 2 56
il travaille dans une sucrerie à
saint-benoît carrés qui s'étend alors de
la rivière du bar à la rivière de l'est
par un panneau appartient à ce
territoire sa première lettre à son ami
villes d'eager écrite le 28 décembre
1843 permet de situer avec précision son
arrivée dans sept pays
amédée inde sur dix pression il y a
quatre ans
c'est à dire en 1839 après un voyage qui
a duré 23 jours quatre mois cet ami est
décédé à laval 23 février 1846 il a été
rappelé hier son beau souvenir par
métairie dans une lettre reçue en
octobre 1843
auguste loger est présent dans cette
colonie un moment crucial de son
développement économique
d'après des travaux de jean françois
girault et de xavier leterrier
l'industrie sucrière est alors en pleine
transformation
après avoir adopté la technologie de
l'eau laquelle permet de réduire les
frais de fonctionnement
assez rare en 1830 jusqu'en 1830 les
moulins à eau se multiplient de 1830
1840 mais le moulin à vapeur continue
son ascension en 1842
72% des moules s des moteurs sont à
vapeur
78% en 1847 dans l'histoire de la mise
en sucre de l'île saint benoît occupe
une place de choix
l'aîné beaulieu propriété dans cette
localité a été à l'origine de la
première scorer en activité 2008 de 1783
à 1788 ce quartier a bien participé
ensuite au premier boom sucrier de 1810
à 1834 il a accueilli 38 une signe de
huit avants 1821 21% et 22 entre 1824
1830 4 soit 58 % le nombre d usines
plafonne en 1834 25 27 puis chez aphatie
et de 1838 la grave crise de 1830 1831
ne semble pas avoir touché cette commune
à ce père fils est en cannes s'élève à
4000 hectares en 1838 à saint-benoît
comme dans les autres communes de l'est
les habitations sucreries et autres
éviter les basses terres même les
terroirs riche du code la rivière du mât
jusqu'à l'arrivée ma soins elles sont
nombreuses sur les pentes fertiles le
bras panon un premier
groupe de sucreries est implanté entre
la rivière du mât et la rivière des
roches le plus souvent à proximité de
l'eau c'est utile pour actionner les
premiers moulins un deuxième a été
construit entre la rivière des roches et
la ravine sèche et un troisième ensemble
des feux se situe à l'est de la ravine
sèche les premiers usines se localise
pour la plupart aux alentours de la côte
sans juste avant les fortes entre se
vend les canes des plaques toccanier qui
se trouve juste au dessus d'elle puis
des basses terres et se créent les plus
récents respecte cette localisation mais
quatre d'entre elles se trouvent en
position basse par parfois même près de
la mer pendant son séjour augusto loger
gère la soirée de bras cannot qui est en
fonction des années dès 1820 à 10 858 je
passe l'historique de cette usine que je
présente malgré tout dans un document
qui sera édité en
1836 un acte notarié précise que cette
structure a déjà adopté la machine à la
vapeur quand augusto logique écrit à
madame agathe jeunesse les le 31 août
1941 une de ces journées pendant le
temps de la manipulation de la can
moments de grand travail pour reprendre
son expression
ils mentionnent l'existence de la pompe
à vapeur voilà ce qu'il dit à deux
heures du matin on met le feu à la pompe
qui fait tourner le moulin à cannes
alors je lève jour la sucrerie je fais
nettoyer les chaudières et les à 3
heures du matin on allume le feu souvent
je fais en forme et le sucre fait la
veille et lorsque le jour est venu que
le temps est beau je vais et gants de la
cour à paillettes bagasse qui ont
asséché la journée et c'est bien de
combustible dès 8 heures je fais
étendent le sucre pour le sécher et à 11
heures on appelle pour déjeuner ce repas
de même que le dîner se compose
de riz qui remplace le pain de braid est
convaincu alloués à la grèce de carrie
viande cuit dans une sauce de safran le
poisson est souvent de marina de rôti de
tortues de de bichiques espèce de petit
toi ton particulier à bourbon ajoutez à
cela une foule de rougail et de sauce
poivre et pimentée et vous aurez une
idée de la manière dont est servie
notament créole je m'accommode de cette
manière de vivre
après le déjeuner je vais à la sucrerie
soir à pompe je donne les vivres noir je
fait peser en mal et le subtil et sec je
monte quelquefois à l'habitation visiter
le travail puis à 6 heures il fait nuit
je rentre à la sucrerie d'un secteur ne
dit non mais à 10 heures le travail
cesse et je veux couche ainsi se passe
mes journées au dos d'âne cette unité de
production de ce qui fonctionne pendant
20 heures chaque jour pendant le temps
de la manipulation la can les esclaves
travail forcément par équipe et par
roulement car si le repos de la nuit de
dieu que quatre heures leur corps ne
pourrait supporter un des rides même
s'il pense beaucoup de mal des esclaves
il faut retenir que ce géreur n'est pas
constamment aurait le soutien us à sucre
riz ils sont spécialisés de leur tâche
c'est pourquoi il ne sent pas que nul
est surveillé en permanence quand il
déjeune ce travail reste à leur procédé
de même qu'en l'après midi il va visiter
les travailleurs des champs c'est
tellement comment des êtres la rappeler
à l'homme les défaillants mais il n'est
pas en mesure de les conseiller le
louvre âge d'auguste logique commence
par la nouvelle des cas de créole de la
première partie ravine sèche est à la
gloire de l'autre certes son intérêt
pour cet élément ne n'est pas dans cette
colonie et cite d'ailleurs pour
introduire cette nouvelle quelques vers
du poème de victor hugo chutes du rhin
mais l'élu tropicale contribuer à
intensifier sa part ne peut être
évacuées ou minorer les nouvelles prône
des dac située à la fin de son séjour
entre le 28 janvier 1944 et le 28
juillet 1945 mais sa rédaction a
sûrement débuté bien avant 1944 quand il
signale qu'elle m'a permis de me blesser
loisirs pendant son temps de présence
dans cette petite colonie française de
l'océan indien elles sont d'abord paru
en feuilleton dans le journal l'écho de
la bayard et de la mayenne cet ouvrage
n'est tiré qu'à 50 exemplaires qui ne
doit d'intéresser que ses amis ne que
les amis de l'auteur l'imprimeur a bien
pour ambition de donner une plus grande
audience car le livre circule à cette
époque entre les mains des familles et
des amis il pense aussi aux immigrations
fut tué comme un must logis est lui a
dédié une grande partie de ses nouvelles
il avoue des rendus note liminaire qu'il
cède aux demandes réitérées par des amis
de l'auteur ce qui lui permet de lui au
foyer un garage un faible garage de son
estime et de sa reconnaissance en effet
sur cinq nouvelles toi on était dédiée à
son ami jeunesse les deltas le créole
bras de fer est là cavernes d'oscar et
une à sa femme julie logis saint félix
et et à une à son ami alexandre
villedieu la vallée du gier fier ce
seceg nouvelle droit du comprennent
qu'une partie et deux en en plus
des italo créole se compose de deux
parties la ravine sèche suivi de le fou
et la vallée du girou palier 3 le
tombeau philogène le jardinier et la
chute de l'or il n'est pas exagéré de
dire que ces partis sont des nouvelles
dans la nouvelle est que le nombre de
nouvelles célèbre définitive à 8
l'originalité des nouvelles l'auguste
loger tient d'abord dans le fait qu'elle
met en scène le lieu où il a vécu et
travaille pendant son séjour bra kanon
lieu-dit de saint-benoît rarement
évoquée par les écrivains il offre une
description détaillée et poétique d'une
part de la ravine sèche qui prend sa
source au sommet des moraines située à
l'ouest de saint benoît et d'autre part
d'un de ces bassins dénommé la grande
marmite
le rapport des brawn et à la nature est
alors particulier il un amour profond de
lille est temps de découvrir ses
moindres recoins il est des hommes en
faisant bon usage de la métaphore la
rivière qui apporte fraîcheur semblerait
que le domaine privilégié ce recueil de
nouvelles est ensuite original profiter
la porte à la connaissance des esclaves
d'une manière générale il des esclaves
africains en particulier
la seconde partie de cet ouvrage
regroupe cinq lettres adressées entre
1840 et 1944 par cet habitant passagers
de l'île bourbon à ses amis en france
hexagonale le notaire m mélé madame
agathe jeunesse les augustes de jeunes
et ses fils monsieur vers dieu et le
bibliothécaire monsieur le tissu les
lettres lui permettre franchement
d'esprit mais franchement son sentiment
sur ces espèces fait l'époque les
expériences vécues au fil des jours et
notamment son émerveillement devant la
beauté de la nature trois d'entre elles
à 3e 4e et 5e lettres nir des
descriptions des paysages découverts
lors de ces matchs entreprises soit lors
de l'interruption volcanique soit lors
de la visite d'un site pittoresque tels
les temps celles ci ne sont pas dénués
d'intérêt mais apporte peu sur la
question sociale qui nous intéresse au
plus haut chef pour ne pas éloigner
ouvrage l'imprimeur ne peut les passe
entièrement certaines lettres il ne
retient que la partie consacrée à la
découverte de sites de l'île à 3 hamlet
n'est que le fragment d'un courrier
envoyé à madame est ce les notaires le 9
août 1940 dans lequel il décrit la
coulée volcanique commencé le 24 juin
1940 dont il a pu entreprendre la visite
le 15 août suivant
comme tous les visiteurs de cette
merveille géologie il les vaut
dessinateur salette les menus détails de
son périple il donne d'abord une
déception du point de l'arrivée adresse
qui sait être limitée aux communes de
saint benoît et de sainte rose
pour les habitants temporaire à la
recherche de singularité et de
sensations fortes la vue d'une coulée
volcanique et si mystérieuse et
envoûtante qu elle excite leurs
curiosités une visite ne suffit pas pour
faire ample connaissance avec ce
deuxième élément
tenté de le connaître et appréhender ses
secrets
leucan augusto logés étaient les rangs
sur ce point car son premier voyage est
suivi d'un second à quelques mois
d'intervalle d'un cinquième en voit qui
est un fragment d'une aide d'une lettre
expédiée le 1er septembre 1844 ce le
tissier
bibliothécaire il évoque son second
voyage au volcan effectué le 7 juillet
2,54
644 zidane est important qu'à la coulée
a atteint la mer nombreux sont les
curieux vaillant et téméraires qui ont
pu savourer le combat titanesque entre
l'eau et le feu qui après avoir tout
brûler sur son passage capitule et perd
dans sa cinquième dans sa 4ème l'inté
spézet à monsieur auguste chez nestlé le
1er septembre 1942 augusto logique quand
sa première promenade à l'étang le 7
juin 1940 un site pittoresque
d'inventer parler créole conduit par un
escale malgache après plus d'une heure
de massage et se trouve sur les bords de
l'étang et en pal avec délectation
j'en passe là pour gagner un peu de
temps la citation cet admirateur de la
nature ne limite pas ses déceptions
qu'au phénomène géologique ou aussi
naturel grandiose de la nouvelle vallée
du girou plier la première partie le
tombeau dénonce l'ingratitude des colons
qui n'ont pas su entretenir et conserver
le jardin d'acclimatation
véritable patrimoine végétal laissé par
joseph hubert qu'il dénomme la vallée du
girou flier l'iran ainsi à sa manière
hommage à ce botaniste autodidacte
reconnu par pierre poivre est devenu
membre de l'académie des sciences la
description attachant du bras madeleine
qu'elle fournit est aussi une magnifique
ation de la nature bonheur en descendant
le bras madeleine ceux de rouler au lit
de l'arbre agilement bout de sa pan et
de fillier sauvage entre deux lianes on
arrive dans une petite vallée que la
nature ça me vois créé pour le bonheur
champêtre entourée de remparts pourquoi
ce cas ne liez de ceylan et le giro
relié des moluques cette nouvelle tant
paix et qui nécessitent délicieux
comprendre qu'on trouve à l'île bourbon
au milieu du bouleversement général des
volcans d'autrefois malgré les
modifications du paysage convoqué par
l'extension des cultures vivrières et
spéculative depuis cent soixante dix
neuf ans avec augusto logel il reste une
terre d'harmonie l'ercim l'eau pure en
abondance le feu qui sourd des
entrailles de la terre quand c'est lui
plaît demeure que charmé et envoûté
nouvelle et lettres selon des sources
totalement différente si les lattes
constituent de véritables cris du coeur
et spots des expériences vécues par lui
par contre les nouvelles s'appuie sur
des récits aux trans me donne les
familles aisées ou pas des esclaves la
nuit avant leur coup chez eho cueillis
par l'oqre elles font référence à des
événements historiques précis mais la
trame des faits peut avoir un lointain
rapport avec la réalité l'évocation
orale autorise toutes les modifications
désiré par le conteur l'ajout
d'enluminures la soustraction des faits
gênants accusateurs même le cadre
géographique peut être modifié malgré
les réserves émises à pâte à propos des
nouvelles de tels documents de tels
documents ne peuvent être délaissés par
l'historien karine pose clairement un
problème qui est toujours d'actualité
celui les liens entre mémoire et
histoire
les nouvelles comme les langues
d'ailleurs apporte des informations
inédites sur la question de parler des
esclaves et des détails sur le
biquotidien ni qu'aucune autre source ne
pourrait nous offrir oui bien que cet
exposé comporte trois parties donc la
première c'est la mémoire n'est pas
l'histoire la deuxième
consiste à parler de parler des esclaves
et la troisième la vie quotidienne donc
mal et noir n'est pas l'histoire la
nouvelle st félix présente deux acteurs
royaliste de l'époque révolutionnaire à
l'île bourbon le militer à saint félix
et la mi-temps des enchères mais le
premier est réservé qu de façon
inattendue du manteau plus
recommandables du révolutionnaire et les
transformer en un commis de la
république venu apporter le décret
d'abolition de l'esclavagé du 4 février
voté par la convention nationale
comme la colonie est hostile à la
libération des esclaves
il est obligé de ces deux se cachait dès
son arrivée dans l'île
d'ailleurs il ne peut être pendu en
essayer de créer car il arrive dans les
mascareignes avant mais 794 la
modification de la réalité très subtil
lawrence inverse ce ne sont pas des
blancs
qui lui pendent généralement assistance
jaune allemand assistance mais des
esclaves
transformer en esclaves marrons
ce qui tend à signifier qu'il est le
régal dès lors qu'il est royaliste et
les deux styles aux gouvernants il ne
vaut pas mieux que les esclaves qui ont
refusé de subir le joug de l'eau m haies
ont choisi de se mettre en marronnage
dans la nouvelle dès son arrivée en
esclaves marrons et sa femme pourtant
déshumanisé accepte par humanité de le
prendre en charge ils acceptent de
courir car il est dans la même situation
qu'eux il est réduit à l'état de marrons
il est dans l'illégalité
et il est activement recherché sa
couleur devient un fardeau pour lui
il est dans la même situation que les
esclaves marrons par affinités
politiques
par humanité et solidarité un
propriétaire de cartier de saint-benoît
monsieur des enchères bien stationnaire
c'est le directeur qui a donné pour
mission à deux hémisphères bako et
muriel nez dans les mascareignes pour
apporter le décret mansi batteur et
veiller à son application
il s'arrête d'abord aller de france
chassé par les colons ils ne font pas
appel aux militaires qui les
accompagnent sous les nappes seul navire
pour réussir coûte que coûte leur
mission il quitte cette île et il se
garde bien de venir à l'est le bois mon
cas ils ne s'adonnent pas un meilleur
accueil dès lors saint-félix n'a aucun
rapport avec ce décret et la venue dans
les mascareignes pour une autre raison
et s'est rendu de son plein gré c'est
chez les enchères les esclaves marrons
n'ont jamais été en lien avec lui cet
épisode de l'histoire de lille bordeaux
est bien connu grâce aux travaux de
claude manqué et se déroule
l'année dernière
et il se déroule dans un contexte
historique n'ont évoqué dans le récit
d'auguste se loger
il s'agit d'une séquence de la lutte des
sans culottes
contre les comptes l'erreur contre les
contre révolutionnaires
conde les
royalistes la référence à l'abolition de
l'esclavagé rodez elle est là pour
redorer l'image du noble saint félix ce
militaire nommé pour assurer la défense
de l'île de france attachés à nos
anciens se fait d'abord brillé avant
d'accepter que de s'énerver
assure la sécurité des navires regagner
la france hexagonale portant un très
lourd magot une 40 millions de livres
d'accepter que deux navires noka sur la
sécurité de sept navires gagne à la
france hexagonale
puis il refuse de défendre les intérêts
de la france en aide
quand elle passe à bourbon il est
poursuivi par les sans culottes comme
ces derniers lui mènent la vie dure et
finit par se rendre aux autorités pour
apaiser les esprits et ramener le calme
au final il n'est pas le porteur du
décret d'abolition des sauvages mais au
royal est proche de la société des amis
de l'ordre
et en tant que compte révolutionnaire il
doit faire face à la réunion aux audaces
des sans culottes de la colonie mais
aussi au sens que l'homme l'île de
france cette nouvelle
sort la localité de bras panon de
l'ombre cas des enchères
abrite saint-félix sur ses terres dans
ce lieu-dit
auguste laugier présente cette localité
de la sorte devant nous se déroulait la
plaine du bras panon avec ses vastes
champs de cannes d'un côté la vaste mer
bleu comme le ciel n'est pas se met
devant le blanche brizay c'est flou des
crimes contre les rochers du bourbier de
l'autre côté au dessus des montagnes de
saint benoît et démons du grand étang le
voyons dans le lointain les pointes des
salazes dominé par le pit ordinaire et
géant à la pointe de glace et la
chevelure de nuages qui se dresse au
milieu de l'île aux deux 3067 m
le vice amiral de saint-félix apparaît
sur la scène politique réunionnaise à
partir de novembre 1793 né dans
l'albigeois en 1737 il arrive en 1771 à
port-louis de l'île de france où il
participe aux guerres de l'aide et pose
une créole et possède une habitation
il revient en juillet 1791 à la tête
d'une division composée de quatre gars
qui l'a conduite en aide
le 1er janvier mais c'est à 93 il est
nommé vice amiral et commandant de la
station naval de l'océan indien il a
quelques ennuis avec ses équipages
canton mai 1793 il revient au port ouest
est donc à lille choses comme il compte
s'en tenait aux directives du liste de
la marine monge as se voir assurer la
sécurité des mascareignes il déplaît aux
autorités populaire de france les
chaumières
quand il souhaitera fin du mois de juin
n'utiliser qu'un navire au lieu de deux
pour escorter un convoi marchand qui
doit regagner l'europe je vous ai dit
dans la richesse des passes au moins 46
millions et n'obtempère qu'après une
réponse écrite du commencement du
commandant civile le boucher et société
populaires sont mécontentes et
l'accusent de connivence avec l'anglais
bien vite il est au coeur d'un nouveau
conflit comme pour digérer est alors
menacé par mer et par terre cvx accepte
les conditions de la division renforce
et pas des concerts mais au moment où
les scans parti et le 21 août il annonce
à l'assemblée coloniale que l'intérêt la
voie de la patrie lui occasionne des
défendent plutôt l'un d'entre eux points
le s&p l'expédition qui l'éloignerait du
poste qui lui a été confié sa lettre
occasionne des débats passionnés à
assembler ces quelques députés
critiquent l'efficacité de l'expédition
en aide la majorité lui demandent
d'obéir aux ordres du peuple de l'île de
france qui considère que la sécurité de
leurs réelles exige d'aller combattre en
aide il retourne à ses bacs de mariée
mais ceux-ci se content de croiser à
proximité de l'île fausses au bout de
quelques jours un temps affreux les
oblige à revenir se mettre à l'abri la
situation du dessin mural et portables
lescar qui a pour mission d'assurer la
sécurité de l'île de france stationnent
dans son bureau comme une étrangère et
les relations entre les officiers
habitants sont conflictuelles
c'est un des buts est modéré veulent en
découdre
il propose de voter sa forfaiture le
démonte de le dénoncer la convention
mais l'assemblée coloniale se limite à
exposer à convention nationale
son projet d'expédition en aide
donc les démêlés sont
nombreux entre l'assemblée coloniale ni
de france est ce un phénix
est infini
pour apaiser la situation ne prend la
décision de venir ici
de venir se mettre ainsi à l'abri
assemblée de l'île de france
naturellement on est en contact avec le
gouverneur local et il craint une
révolte des
bonnets des sans culottes de la réunion
finalement son débarquement se passe
bien
il n'y a pas de soulèvement local et
sa présence à beaumont est mal acceptée
par les sans culottes de l'île de france
et ils vont décider d'envoyer une
délégation pour
pour vous pour arrêter les
royalistes les plus influents de l'île
et d'arrêter également simple x donc on
a une trentaine de militaires d'une île
de france qui vont venir dans une
mémorable la nuit du 11 au 12 avril 794
ils vont effectivement arrêté quelques
quelques membres de la société des amis
de l'ordre de le bonbon mais ils
n'arrêteront pas saint félix et
naturellement ceux qui sont arrêtés vont
être jugés et
au final
tous vos têtes élargit donc pour ne pas
exciter les esprits en
1795 la situation retourne à peu près à
la normale j'ai courtes un peu pour ne
pas rentrer dans tous les détails de
cette
de la présence
problème composer la présence de
saint-félix dans la zone dans l'île mais
il a trouvé refuge chez un créole de
saint-benoît donc on a dit des enchères
qu'elles cachent dans les eaux de son
habitation de bras panon car il voulait
rester dans la colonie jusqu'à l'arrivée
des décisions de la convention nationale
le disculpant total
sa cachette est connue de quelques
proches de villèle riverains esparon et
2,3 esclaves chargé de lui apporter sa
nourriture donc des patrouilles sont
envoyés pour le rechercher
et finalement il va se décider de
se rendre aux autorités
à saint-andré
et c'est cet épisode est finalement qui
et qui a été racontée dans l'est lorsque
loger là cinquante ans après
et on voit très bien que entre ce qui
est raconté
et transcrit par l'ogec et la réalité
des faits eh bien il ya une marge
mais
il faut bien reconnaître que la mémoire
est oublieuse
lc combler les vides maquillé ce qui
risque de déplaire aux puissants du
moment et à force d'être répétées des
mensonges finissent par passer pour des
vérités le souci premier de feu lui qui
raconte un fait historique des pannes
s'en tenir à la réalité chaque passeurs
de mémoire agit à sa guise obéit à ses
propres règles
dans la vallée du girou flier
[Musique]
qui expose le sort d'un esclave
jardinier chez joseph hubert
est bien le problème 2
la mémoire de l'histoire se repose à
nouveau avec autant d'acuité ce grand
propriétaire
déclare de
découvre un soin de cyclones l'esclave
jean-louis
chargée de surveiller le plus beau et
ancien girofliers de son jardin
et le décor qui est en train de le
protéger de son corps et de ses bras
nerveux il est sidéré par cette scène et
ils en ont déduit que cet esclave m
c'est à mieux que lui car il est prêt à
mettre en sa vie en danger pour le
sauver et est décédé sur le champ de
présenter à l'administration
sa demande d'affranchissement le 27 mars
1791 le jour de la libération effective
de jean-louis joseph hubert prononce un
dico un discours pathétique sur les bons
services rendus par cet esclave
jardinier la passion de cet esclave pour
les plans des telles qu'une fois libre
il souhaite ne pas s'éloigner de ce
jardin et continuer à entretenir comme à
l'accoutumée
au moment où augusto loger ce trou d'un
coup de la colonie au sein de la
population esclave les escrocs sont
majoritaires et parmi les esclaves
importés ou entrer illégalement depuis
la loi d'abolition de la crète en 1817
les africains sont les plus nombreux des
1808 ils représentent 42 % de la
population esclave cette réalité peut
expliquer l'attrait de cet auteur pour
la langue créole et les parler d afrique
dans les années du 140 le palais crayon
l'a déjà une connotation négative
l'africain semblables semble avoir le
plus de difficultés à adopter dans la
franchise française en effet quand son
interlocuteur s'adresse aux petits
blancs des heat a en créole et nos rangs
français il lui demande c'est le propos
en quarts parce que sa figure est allé
parce qu'il porte une chemise bleue qui
ne mâche nu pieds et de la cale plus
pour se vêtir
mais cette remarque ne traduit pas toute
la réalité et dépendamment de la statue
créole et africains centraide et sème
parfois malgré l'interdiction formulée
par l'ordonance de jacob blanquer de
l'aed de descendre 1674 c est moins
visible ces familles interdite en blanc
et noir ont fait l'objet d'une brillante
thèse préparée par sabine noël et ceux
tenus en 2018 à l'université de la
rochelle la nouvelle d icade auguste
loger conforte les conclusions de cette
étude d'état raconte l'histoire du
créole blanc jauge parti à la recherche
de palmiste victime d'une chute ce cours
est secourue par mouna une esclave
marronne une kaffrine de la nation
d'emma quoi la reconnaissance le pousse
à la revoir ils finissent par éprouver
de l'amour impôts lot quand elle est
enceinte elle lui demande d'agir pour
que cet enfant ne connaissent pas le
sort des esclaves comme il est pauvre il
ne peut accepter à sa demande et
racheter son enfant un décide d'aller en
marronnage jusqu'à l'accouchement pour
qu'il puisse déclarer l'enfant en tant
qu' abandonner pour pouvoir l'adopter et
le libérer ce plan est mise en oeuvre
mais ne se réalise pas jusqu'au mont
jauge muna et l'enfant sont emporté par
une crue de la ravine sèche dans bras de
fer après la récupération par les
esclaves à bord d'un cabriolet est
revendiquée par un blanc une réponse en
créole fournis par eux remarque du
chasseur créole sont intéressants sur le
plan linguistique tant par les formules
employées que par l'écriture non
moussier moins grande allée non monsieur
je le serai ses apparitions outils m
mais nous sommes avant ne tirait pas
monsieur six ans tu es un
vous assomme retouches
et veille à great dans ceux des maîtres
la vie à la case n'est vraiment génial
ça ne fera pas mal aveux si vous
regrettez dans cet animal venez chez moi
ne le feront cuire et ne le mangent
ensemble ils vous feront nous ne nous
voulons aucun mal à bas les courses à
bouna points noirs et voulait loin de
vous debout corps si votre coup de fusil
en l'air et bien déjeuné avec nous
vos idées pas l'hiver vous n'avez pas
d'esclaves et votre cas des crises
éloigné du lieu où vous n y circulent
fusée en l'air ou vrai que ça ne sert à
rien car personne ne répondra à vos
appels venaient manger règle
ap ap un bourg blanc nous il fera pas
mal à vous n'ayez pas peur mont blanc
nous ne ferons aucun mal n'a pas pu
mont-blanc
nuit et ma bouche ou travaux le 10
heures à cause brogan vous y reconnaître
chemin qui mène à la quinzaine n'ayez
pas peur bon blanc nous allons vous
bandé les yeux pour que vous ne voyez
pas les sens et qu'il faut emprunter
pour se rendre à notre gîte n'a pas pas
bons blancs - mama ou à cause prend
garde tomber dans l'avant par des
papillons blancs je vous attacher les
mains pour éviter une chute de laurent
pas prend garde ou s'il vous plaît ça
vous n'en avez pas tout regardez bien
vous posez les pieds monsieur vous
risquez ou blessés nous avons disposé
beaucoup de pièges pour protéger notre g
au retour
il doit se plier aux mutuelle
j'espère monsieur
faucon wimbush nouveau les yeux n'a pas
bon que vous écoutez une chine china
j'espère mais ce monsieur que vous
comprendrez que nous sommes obligés de
demander à nouveau vos yeux quand vous
ne devez pas en connaître notre chemin
bradfer le chef de ce peu de cette
petite bande de marrons ne fait aucun
mal à ce blanc parce qu'elle a envers
lui une dette de reconnaissance
un jour pendant son marronnage il a été
arrêté par des esclaves et revenir à
leur maître celui qu'elle maintenant en
face de lui celui ci l'a détaché
alimenter puis remis en liberté depuis
il a nourri le rêve de lui offrir un
repas il a enfin réalisé
vous y rappelle un jour benoît
avait arrêté marne vous la fais là à
gagner vous la donne allait manger
et bien ça marc la nuit même mais la
rend à bout du jeune et vous la bande à
moins asteur de dire qu'il
vous rappeler qu'un joueur aux esclaves
avaient arrêté un mari lui avait enlevé
ses attaches lui avait donné à manger et
bien cette escale à ma roue c'était moi
j'ai vous de vous en sera maintenant
nous sommes qui quand il lui dit qu'il
aurait pu lui rend un repas son repas
semblent prendre le risque de le tuer
ils eurent et or est ce que tu me l'a
pas dit ah vous n'a pas peur bon blanc
tenez voilà votre fusil grève ou de gaz
mais tient bon bout de la langue et dis
pas que vous l'avez bras de fer et que
vous l'a dit je n'ai ensemble ne nous
avait pas dit ne pas avoir eu à
montblanc est-ce qu'ils le savent est
qu'il ne vous sera fait aucun mal tenez
voilà votre fusil retournez chez vous
mais ne racontez pas ce qui s'est passé
ne dites pas que vous avez rencontré
bras de fer et que vous avez déjeuné
avec lui augusto loger disco tout à fait
inattendue cette escale marron réputé
très dangereux
il ne présente pas comme une brute il
réfléchit comme un tueur assoiffés de
sang guidés par l'esprit de vengeance
mais comme un adversaire qui prend
plaisir à faire le bien il s'est
manifesté sa reconnaissance envers le
blanc généreux et humain et il laisse
entendre que le phénotype ne détermine
pas les cubains
à la question comment vivez-vous il
répond nous sied à cabris de la montagne
n'a pas de mise à niveau a à chaque fois
dans la vie lundi mais elle n'allait
viable partout du tout en lui mais il
faut qu'elle nous apprend par assez
prouvé depuis huit descentes chez les
habitants ne prend pas 4 manioc maïs
cochon volaille et nous
démarrons se nourrissent des cabris
présente la montagne n'est pas inscrit
dans les bois et forêts de pêcher dans
les ravines que vient le verts amassés
dans les troncs des rieuse a partout ne
pouvant excéder fouquet dont elles n'ont
pas de difficultés pour assurer leur
survie au quotidien aussi attaqué des
habitations côtières pour récupérer des
batailles du manioc de maïs du manioc du
maïs tu déposes des volailles et à
propos des attaques éventuelles la part
des chasseurs de marrons comme les
esclaves des électeurs on tenait
davantage la connaissance de la montagne
et bien jacques c'est de leur lieu de
vie il ne pense pas que leur cachet
puissent être repérées par des novices
appoint moussier soglo n'a pas capable
de nano du monde connaît pas ça au salut
dans détachement il connaît pas si main
pour un dessin ici à guerre partout en
ar pellouailles la fosse
aguets sur la tête tout ça vous chante à
agacer là-haut en coupant eliane nuit
que fait-on
écrasé disons qu'ils suivent
non monsieur les blancs sont dans
l'incapacité de retrouver et ne
connaissent pas
ou ne nous cachons les détachements ne
peuvent pas arriver jusque là regardez
tous les pièges que nous avons installé
dans le décor plus loin nous avons même
creuser des fosses qui sont également
piégé regarder au dessus de votre tête
des rouches attachées les unes aux
autres panneaux killian en la coupant
toutes les régions ont dégringolé sur
ceux qui voudraient venir jusqu'à nous
tous les blancs ne mérite pas les mêmes
égards de la part des esclaves dans le
fou lorsque des esclaves marrons
d'ivoire georges écrasé par un pas liste
il refuse lui porter assistance mais le
soir quelques noix marois venu à ces
cris de détresse se retirer en disant
c'est un blanc laissant le lin et nous
dénoncerons mais une jeune fille grèce
une ans un geste d'espoir et de tarde
pas à venir à son secours pour
communiquer entre eux des esclaves
importés sont dans l'obligation
d'apprendre au moins le créole dans
saint félix un malgache usent de cette
langue
que ça où il veut qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous
oui moi qu'à moi va volume d'eau et
briques à la fin ou au quai de loire
vous êtes blanc et vous n'avez pas de
quoi manger c'est lorsque saint félix
arrive dans l'île et qu'il rencontre
pour la première fois un escale et
cherchent asile auprès des esclaves et
veulent d'israël afin automatiquement
voilà ce qu'il répond
si vous voulez mieux en france que ça
tient dans la paume est en prison -
changerait pour vous vous la game
mauvaises conditions ainsi ça vaut la
peine
ma place des paiements tonnes ne va au
tir vous va manger si vous venez
d'arriver dans cette colonie et qu'ils
veulent nous mettre en prison je suis
bien désolé pour vous la france vous a
changé d'une mauvaise mission
asseyez-vous j des épis de maïs je vais
les faire rêver je vais février ce sera
votre
âme alcala mona à moustier des enchères
un bon blanc je m'appelle incana je
maintiens monsieur des enchères c'est un
bon mec me suis née papa la nature du
monde dans sa cale la zone introuvable
l'un sa voix fait repose un peu tout à
l'heure j'ai les montants ma vie ni elle
y va mettre à vous dans un endroit que -
koné ou vous sera bien uni blanc n'a pas
capable trouve à monsieur n'allez pas là
cette case est remplie d'hommes
politiques ils vont vous démasquer
laissez moi prendre la situation tout à
l'heure julie ma femme arrivera elle
vous conduira dans un endroit que je
connais qui est sûre où les blancs sont
incapables de vous retrouver la peau des
africains sur le plan linguistique est
mal connue les efforts faits par les
missionnaires dans l'apprentissage de la
langue des esclaves se limite aux
malgaches est au creux c'est le cas de
philippe caullier alexandre monnet
frédéric levasseur peu de documents
permettre d'aborder cette question la
définition fois ni par augusto logé au
moment ci établit son origine africaine
il s'agit de la farine de manioc avec
laquelle les marrons avec des gâteaux de
manioc puis dans une marmite
ce thème a fini par désigner tout faren
puisqu'aujourd'hui le gâteau faire
maintient la farine de maïs est appelée
nancy hollande si cette confidence
d'augusto loger remet encore ce qu
avance jean albany dans son petit
glossaire le paiement des mots créoles
exister en 1974 quand il soutient que ce
mot est d'origine aide il n'a peut-être
pas tout à fait raison auguste loger
pour l'instant le seul auteur a traduit
son intérêt à son intérêt pour les
parler des africains et à poigne et les
expressions utilisées par eux de même
que des dialogues entre
il maîtrise le créole et au moins un
dialecte africain car sur l'habitation
soudaine bra kanon il a été au contact
de ces deux groupes ethnoculturels qui
regroupe le plus d'esclaves en 1828
cette habitation de bric à brac à nos
emplois 56,9 points 20 8% discale créole
30 et avec 2 5% cafres disque de
poissons malgache et un pic de 5 300
indiens lors de la vente faite par
robert théodore de saint-georges avocats
et conseils coloniale à jacques joseph
michel de gagner le 28 avril 1938 d'un
groupe de trente deux esclaves attache
eric sottas aucune terre 53 que
l'impression des escales caf 43 27 fois
son créole trois légumes de poissons
malgache a révélé le bois blond à l'âge
de 26 ans à 9 ans a vécu en afrique
pendant un temps plus ou moins long
c'est bien auprès des esclaves africains
qui s'est familiarisé à la langue de
certaines tribus d'un bras de fer le
chef d'une bonne de marrons donne à
quatre de ses camarades un homme en
s'exprimant dans un dialecte de la
racine et bantous famille droz africaine
parler de la boîte issus du continent
africain
en gamme où c'est alan gold a aidé le
blanc
l'écriture d'augusto logis et phonétique
le saurons dans principe ces créatures
comme l'afrique en groupes plus de 50
pays et dans quelques pays comme la
tanzanie il existe au plus de 120 tribus
ayant chacune une hollande il est
difficile de déterminer aujourd'hui avec
exo attitude la tribu des esclaves qui
sur cette habitation sucre et du barca
note s'ils souhaitent ainsi mais il est
sûr que des escales africaines tribus
différentes vivait sous l'autorité de m
m dans la cabine de ce calme 7e les 26
hommes de l'als sommes des esclaves
africains qui se prépare une révolte le
soir du 1er mai 1944
mélanie d'airé à kolongo bonne son frère
comment google est comme neuf maravic
attendait aussi quitté avec nous demain
on commence à la com des cannes en fait
c'est la révolte à couper des têtes il
va beaucoup la bi kalou ont coûté n'a
les haches des couteaux les sables
coupe-t-il
ou du lait maravic ahola les goulots
elle vous propose demain soir
ayrault bongo oui camarades comment les
cailloux à pépé qu'à lomé bananiers à
kacou lots ne sont pas un homme d'enfin
vieillard coup laga pa sommet les
nippons big bang a cure ça gagne comme
tous les esclaves qui participent à
cette réunion préparatoire ne parlent
pas la même langue ils ont ensuite du
français mais dès qu'ils remarquent ils
sont écoutés par un intrus essais seront
à nouveau dans le direct par les
d'origine est bien celui des opérations
secret il cohabite avec le créole
à langoat now one au blanc 10,6 et
créatives en se jetant sur lui alors que
son confort inouï répondent comme un
collègue accola gars turturro il croit
encore à la réussite de leurs projets
leurs épaules ils sont confiants salam à
koh lanta
koïta cuisse qui t'avait longo à la
poubelle kahn au moment donné le signal
de la tacc fortunés dit halloween à
qu'attendu et commençons puis voyons
qu'il tarde à réagir le prince coude à
coude à turon turon
cui mots coquins kangaba là le vent nous
vivement il blesse son amour-propre
entier du mythique les danseuses l'ont
forcément sort cela il se décide alors à
donner le signal vaut lui en jetant son
mouchoir et on a fait en affirmant qu on
sait qu terminé on gomme
je ne compte pas comme la pluie a
mouillé la poudre et empêche de donner
la lettre à tous les esclaves la
nouvelle la révolte ne peut se répondent
les chèques ne fait plus de 2 dans cet
ouvrage auguste logic et spring sa
perception des esclavages eddy veulent
que quelqu'un quelques créer de la vie
quotidienne des esclaves
d'arkadin d'oscar
auguste le jet relate la désunion au
sein du mont esclaves mais aussi au sein
du monde des maîtres précise qu'avant la
couleur et la fortune de l'homme bien
plus que le méritent tous les talents
reg la considération dont il jouit il
n'existe pas de subdivision de métis le
câble de quoi seront de 15 euros comme
aux antilles ce qu'elle dit à propos de
la répartition des blanches dans le
niveau de fortune et inédit l'expression
créole patates pour désigner les petits
créoles ne créant le port est assez peu
employée par écrit avant le début du 20e
siècle on ne distingue pas on ne
distingue que les esclaves les libellés
blanc cependant un an malgache se
croient plus qu'un qaf1r créole ccim
plus qu'un malgache un ménage se croit
bien supérieur aux esclaves qu'ils
appellent la brute et les libres qui
sont des esclaves affranchis qu'est-ce
qu'on a les égaux des plans parce qu'ils
ont le privilège et protège chaussures
ceux qui la bague la distinction la
liberté dans de blanc ils forment une
espèce de noblesse d'aristocratie de
classes privilégiées qui méprisent
toutes les autres castes parmi eux il ya
les riches les grands propriétaires
qu'on appelle les habitants les points
des terres on petit propriétaire qu'on
appelle les créoles on donne aussi le
nom de créole patate aux misérables qui
ne possède ni terres ni noir qui
s'occupe entièrement que de pêche qui
vivent au jour le jour sous les
paillotes qui se bâtissent au bord des
rivières au sol en images la guerre l
espace réservé par le gouvernement et
qu'on nomme les pas géométriques les
habitants peuvent être comparés aux
riches de france l'éclair le paysan
l'écrire le patin à la classe la plus
misérable les blancs ne salue jamais un
an de couleurs il ne lui donne jamais la
main et ne l'admettent point notable et
lorsqu'il est posé mulâtresse quelques
blanche quelques riches qu'elles soient
qui sont pour insidiae déshonoré ils
cessent les frais que de fréquenter la
société et ne pas présenter leurs femmes
que chez les gens de couleur dans la
première lettre publiée dans cet ouvrage
loger et sponsors sentiments se laissera
pas comme en france les aider à
l'évolutionnisme gagnent du terrain il
ne peut dire décemment qu'il approche
système d'exploitation de l'être humain
pas l'être humain j'ai regretté la
france d' utile
car j'ai vu aussi des esclaves
puisses-tu ne jamais en voir
c'est un spectacle qui affligent la que
celui de leurs à ses dépens
cependant il a du mal à se débarrasser
de naturel car il avance lui que les
idées ne reste que pendant que les et
d'émotion en france ne traduisent pas la
réalité coloniale l'idée de
l'infériorité des droits est pour lui
une évidence il n'hésite pas un seul
instant avait affirmé que les actionner
pour est triste car il lancé demandant
pour devenir civilisé l' esclavage et
pour un passage obligé ils sont
convaincus qu'ils ne se donnent même
plus comment ce système abject petit
civilisé le noir
voilà ce qu'elle était aussi un outil
important car les nex aucune race abouti
que parmi un peuple civilisé il faut
pour leur propre bonheur qui soit
escales qui l'amenait passant de sept
millions de chopes artisanat liberté
même si comme moi qui vivais avec les
noirs si je connaissais comme alors un
besoin que lui ré que leur donner la
liberté s'est délivré à la fin et révisé
de même que les animaux domestiques
pérenne besoin sur les abandonner la
campagne de même les photographes non
mais qu'il soigne dans ces maladies qui
donne une cave qui le nourrit ce qu'il
appelle qui le protège et n'empêche que
se livrent aux pillages
pour lui
toutes les images véhiculées en france
parler des profils sont fausses à partir
de la réalité de bons canaux de bra
kanon il conclut que les noirs bobos
sont les plus heureux d être sumène de
famille me théry qui a passé quatre mois
avec moi bras au bras kanon et qui a vu
la manière dont traiter les contraintes
et les noirs tout détrompera sur le gong
de réconciliera avec les colons
si tenté que du soin des gros films et
te dire à benoît
compo paraît alignées au cordeau c'est
un petit village chaque rien c'est une
case en bois couvert très divers or à
quoi elle est entourée d'un petit chalet
où il cultive des légumes des bananes et
tu tapes à penza case et au diamant un
petit parc lebas enferme ses cochons il
aimait aussi des volailles et de ses
animaux sur sa propriété sacré leblanc
n'y touchez jamais la vie au travail est
un paradis le matin au jour des doigts
se présentent à la peine puis ils vont
au travail consiste le plus
ordinairement à gratter la terre avec
une pioche ce qui est beaucoup moins
fatigant que c'était travaux de la
campagne chez nous vers 9h et une demi
heure pour déjeuner à midi on leur donne
une heure de repos et un pain de riz
pour le dîner et le soir à la nuit
tombante ils reviennent à l'emplacement
reçoivent une nouvelle ration de riz est
rentré et rendent dans leur case ainsi
ainsi se passe la journée et quand même
entre les tropiques les jours ne sont
dignement que de 12 heures il en résulte
qu'ils auront moins matin de l'auteur a
eu les travaux de ce corps et exige plus
d'assiduité mais ne sont pas plus
pénibles
célestin sont mal vécues mal vécu c'est
de l'offre car le vêtement distribuer le
premier de langues et vendu par cet
énorme d'entre eux les cavs sont montrés
du doigt car elle refuse de porter un
vêtement l'écart secours le plus souvent
avec des bonis emballages de rides ou ne
mettre que lang outil qui est mon seul
toit la barrière au bas des reins les
règlements de police s'en défende aller
au quartier de mâche et cela quand
d'autres sans avoir glissé un pantalon
et bien j'en vois souvent tout leur
pantalon chemise autour de l'hôtel les
mecs quand l'un d'entre eux quand ils
appellent en sortez sortez qui se
battent de l'ailé quitter sa description
de l'hétérogénéité du monde des esclaves
basé sur les aptitudes intellectuelles
et pas seulement sur la force physique
est originale mais elle n'exclut pas au
final les clichés traditionnels
parmi les noyés trois castes principal
les créoles soient les plus
intelligentes et les plus propres points
de médecine on en fait des maçons et
charpentiers et surtout des domestiques
les malgaches sont à ses industries
industries eux et sont généralement
faibles et entêté les caf sont les plus
brutes et plus docile le plus fort de
tous ont les emplois aux travaux des
champs sa présentation des peuples de
les applications 10e et ces précisions
sur le tatouage pose la même question de
l'initiation pose la question de
l'initiation dans leur entraîneur d'un
circuit de la traite on en compte plus
aux nations telles que l'ema quale
marave et nous qui avoient semé monial
et marcondes et les nombreuses et yugo
l'autre et les bibis chacune à son
tatouage particulier les marckois potins
sur le front un croissant à verser les
mâcon des ondes et les sur les joues et
la coke et des oreilles percées l'ayant
ban et les bibis on sur le nez et le
froid une rangée de vers grosses comme
des grains de maïs toutes ces marques
sont regardés par peu comme non gélives
mans et disent que sans cela dans leur
pays on ne regardait pas comme des
hommes et que sur et que pour les
obtenir et souffrent les incisions très
douloureuse il a peut être aussi les
leurs dans aux moyennes les pour être
plus fort ou tousser peuvent si barbare
et ses méchants sur la côte d'afrique
sortie si doux et paisible comme des
moutons ses derniers mots justifie la
mise en esclavage des africains allaient
le bonbon cet épisode de la vie leur a
été salutaire car ils ont été
transformés s'égailler rebelles sont
devenus tout comme l'agneau d'après des
confidences qui lui aurait été faite en
afrique ils avaient l'habitude de se
faire la guerre la violence leur écoute
lumière tout d'être no payer toute
injure mettant en jeu la mer déclenche
immédiatement une bagarre
traduction à leur fond de pensée l'ap le
fond de leur pensée la question mérite
d'être posée ici faune guerre
continuelle brûlant et saccageant tout
que lorsqu ils en veulent à quelqu'un il
attend le passage le cul avec d'un coup
de sagaie mais coupe la tête et les
mains placées trophée devant la case
pour qu'on voit qu'ils sont roms et
mille autres traits de barbarie qui met
deux fois dresser les cheveux et qui
leur paraissent tout naturel ils se font
justice eux mêmes ne conçois pas que
dans le pays blanc et fighter de ford
formalité pour couper le cou d'un homme
une dette et pour le plus puissant
mortiers de vengeance il s'arrache
impitoyablement leur chemise profond
pour la plus faible somme aussi
lorsqu'il se disputent il commence
toujours par se dire est ce que moi il
est à toi
malavolta manger la plus grosse un jeu
quelque peu se dire ces deux jurés le
père ou la mère quand un café dialogue
qui promène un peu à toi en fin de
chaîne tout moment il accueille ici il
cultive l'amour familial puisque le
supporte pas que le mais à cet âge
huriez
il est le seul auteur a évoqué le dieu
des africains mais son discours est très
ambigu et contradictoire
en effet après avoir souligné qu'ils
n'ont pas de religion et parle de l'an
dieu qu'il représente de manière
singulière avec un bras une jambe un
deuil qui est redoutable et qui ne doit
point il prétend un parent n'a pas revu
de fait de fétiches sur eux at il établi
une relation de confiance pour qu'ils
acceptent de témoigner sérieusement ce
sujet très intime
l'échantillon d'esclaves africains
qu'ils fréquentent et interroge à bra
kanon est elle représentative pour se
faire une juste opinion de la pratique
religieuse la question mérite pour
composer les africains donc là je dis ce
qu'a dit les africains donc une religion
est le dieu qu'il adore point est une
espèce de lutte de farfadets qu'ils
appellent maroc et qui se présente sous
la forme la plus bizarre haute de deux
pieds n'ayant qu'une jambe qu'un bras
qu'un oeil courant la nuit pour faire
peur aux gens les pâtes les tourmenter
en un mot un vrai loup garou 1 est
essentiellement malfaisants il commence
à croix de corps je commence à croire
que toutes les histoires de fétiches
dans les comptes car je n'en ai vu avec
les noirs je n'ai jamais vu avec les
noirs et lorsque je leur en ai parlé et
m'ont tous dit que dans leur pays et y
en avait pas ces informateurs africain
appartenant à des peuples différents le
mot utilisé pour désigner dieu varie
dans sa deuxième lettre le terme ou
longo apparaît dans les ouvrages la
philosophie bantoue comparer du
professeur k gamme une carte présente à
localisation des termes employés pour
désigner qu il existe plus d'une
cinquantaine de noms de dieu en fonction
des langues parlées l'idée générale qui
se dégage son vocabulaire celle
désignant dieu comme le pré existants
elle est unique qui existe avant toute
réalité existante celui qui est au bout
de toutes les séries de causalité et en
dehors de toutes les catégories d'être
possible sera la culture bantou lui par
alexis gamme des piètres pietro loupe
dieu se présente comme lot par
définition regardez autre réalité de
l'univers le pré existant est alors
transcendant est nécessaire transcendant
justement parce que par essence et les
autres est différent nécessaire parce
que sans lui le réel ne serait jamais
intelligent voire possible en tanzanie
cette aide préexistants étape les
créateurs façonniers dominateur gardia
bienfaiteurs aux high et en ouganda il
est perçu comme l'architecte qui
planifie et organise univers où comme
celui qui est l'organisateur par
excellence le mozambique et fille
diffusé dans une dizaines de variantes
du cameroun jusqu'au congo l'ancien
zaïre et selon alexis carra gamme la
racine de se taire compote l'idée de
dire quelque chose avec énergie le thème
les à signifiant le tout puissant est
présent dans plusieurs régions de
l'afrique centrale mokolo le très
puissant et en principe est en usage au
zimbabwe et dans certaines régions du
mozambique dans les religions d'afrique
noire de lui vincent thomas et de rené
luneau
ses auteurs ne met pas en doute
l'existence une religion africaine celle
ci comporte d'ailleurs de nombreuses
démarches qui rappelle successivement ou
simultanément
l'animisme le totémisme
lancestre isme humanisme le naturisme
fait le fétichisme et le paganisme la
religion se présente comme une
ordination de puissance au sommet se
placent les suprêmes souvent il s'agit
d'un dieu inaccessible qui depuis la
création n'a que peu de rapport direct
avec le monde et les hommes il
abandonner le pouvoir un moment à un
moniteur crs la plupart du temps les
êtres humains ne lui adresse un culte
partiel et indirects
mieux encore il n'a pas fanny d'eni
officiant il est lointain il n'a que
faire des prières des humains il aura
donné ses fétiches ces génies pour les
aider et s'en servir cette ethnie
conçoivent un être suprême créateur
transcendant d'où l unicité à la fois
omniscient et omnipotent source et
principes de la vie d'autres ethnies
voir l'être divin une entité créatrice
et peut être attribuée au dieu des
comportements humains d'où l'existence
de dieu mal rattaché au soleil à la
pluie foudres de dieu femelle liés à la
terre la lune à l'eau de dieu androgyne
et de dieu formant un couple
indissociable l'être suprême aurait
dévolu à des génies une tâche précise
presque de cosmic régler les phénomènes
naturels marais force des vents
écoulement des fleuves et à des
divinités secondaire le soin de ses
vielles de relais entre l'être humain et
l'acsi poèmes trop souvent lointains
images religieuses s'impose après
l'éruption d'un des zones c'est à dire
d'une rupture de l'equilibre d être
fausse sécheresse excessive et subit mon
en série épidémies et les outils échec
des techniques habituellement déficiente
fait interprété par la conscience
collective comme une vengeance des
puissances célestes et puissant sacré
consécutive un manquement grave et cela
mounir les choses multiples doivent
accompagner les mutations profondes de
chaque individu les changements de
personnalité ces considérations nous
pousse à douter de remarques de bus de
loger s'il pas été le jouet des escales
qu'il a été roger assez d'être un dieu
le dira car leur conception à leur
manière de représenter dieu qui
apparaissent ici sont assez étonnantes
elles sont à contre courant de ce qui se
dit en afrique sur dieu qui est le pré
existants le dominateur très puissant en
dépit des concepts utilisés la
perception de dieu est toujours positive
alors que chez auguste loger elle est
totalement négative la perception d'une
si les maîtres abusent de leur autorité
pour le jour la nuit dieu sans prendre
le relais pour tourmenter les vivants en
distillant lalibela 2 la peur de leur
dieu peut-être veut-il faire popularisé
l'idée de leur accessibilité à toutes
les autres religions s'il est vrai
alors peut-être est-ce une menace en
direction dé m il décrit les esclaves
comme des individus naïf ayant peu de
mots pour exprimer des idées abstraites
ils ne sont pas une excuses sur les
choses les plus frivole boire manger
dormir copuler la question posée à une
bonne de caf ou le cojo le soleil se
couche et il le moins inspiré répond je
ne sais pas mais le plus malin rusé qui
va se baigner en dhr la montagne
derrière la montagne puis revient de
cinq à dix pendant la nuit
quant à la lune elle se bat avec le
soleil quant à laurent compte l'esclave
africa n'a pas la même conception de
nature que l'européen la succession des
jouets des nuits les cycles lunaires les
mouvements du soleil lui offrit un
mystérieux l'orage n'a rien d'un
terrifiant et de plus il annonce la
pluie bienfaisante
les humains ne fait qu'un avec la nature
il anime dans ce cosmos construit en
totalité
l'être humain n'est qu'un traducteur de
signe un créateur de force verbales
comme leur apprentissage d'une langue
française est récent il est normal que
leur vocabulaire sont encore restreints
et qu'ils aient du mal à exprimer leur
pensée en trouvant le mot juste dans
leur réponse d'une conviennent ne
conviennent pas aux bustes loger il ne
vient pas à l'esprit de s'interroger sur
la pertinence à questions il est
vraiment stupéfait quand un esclave dit
que le sort d'un aveugle est à plaindre
parce qu'ils ne voient pas ce qu'ils
mangent il n'est pas vraiment sur la
même fréquence que son informateur car
ils sont incapables comprendre que la
crainte du poison pouces l'esclave
encoder beaucoup d'importance à ce qui
était trop dieu de sa bouche il faut
voir pour croire le goût ne suffit pas
la nouvelle bras de fer révèle deux
faits d'une grande importance à celui
qui désire
cerner la vie quotidienne des escarres
baroin d'abord les pièges employés pour
interdire l'accès des locaux et
étrangers au chat sur le maroc donc je
sois des pics et qu'il met à l'intérieur
du sol ensuite il évoque aussi la
technique pour faire du feu de bois sans
fumée aucune autre source ne peut nous
procurer de tels détails la grotte était
plein de petit paquet de lois dont on
avait tiré cause d'un discours tout
autour il y avait des branches sèches
qu'on ne voudrait pas ça déboite balaie
la journée quand des voix sauf du côté
saint benoît ne vole pas ne ibru l'année
à cause il y donne pas de fumée
autrement c'est la fumée viendrait se la
fumée la rivière berne seydou bamba les
deux l'employons la journée quand le
vent chaud quand le vent de mai vient de
saint-benoît cas il ne dégage pas de
fumée autrement nous serions repérer
facilement dans saint félix il signe à
l'utilisation du benjoin pour noircir le
corps que français fuyards
caracal apparaît avec rouleau des causes
de benjoin saint félix et demande ce
qu'il compte en faire nous sur réponses
et me fait bouillir la marmite dit löw
va venir doit vous frottez vous d'accord
avec ça et où il sera en bois l'âme
comme moi même parce que c'est un
malgache audois dame qui parle avec
monsieur pour brouiller ses écosse de
benjoin dans une marmite d'eau
celle ci deviendra noir vous allez vous
frotter votre corps et vous allez
devenir noir comme moi l'envoie là il se
déguise en esclaves pour ne pas s
arrêter car mille piastres ont été
premiers à celui qui le livrant aux
autorités de l'île cette prime attise
des convoitises et pour l'avoir la
délation aussi bien chez les blancs
c'est ce qu'a fait riverains esparon et
chez les esclaves
michel et alexis qui n'assisstait ont
aussi
dénoncé
saint-félix puisqu'elle vit dans
l'illégalité il est devenu noir car
colonnes sa peau désormais le trail
la longue ballade la deuxième note
écrite à madame agata genès la bonne des
manières de vivre globaux les habitudes
des esclaves dans ce pays pour les
blancs la vie est douce et ennuyeuse la
nourriture abondante et variée
c'est le climat est agréable
auguste logis souffre de la monotonie de
la nature qu'elle ne supporte pas le
vert
il lui montre l'hiver glacial la nature
en deuil
couverte de neige blanche les oranges et
les palmiers les jeux reflet y ait tant
vanté par c'était l'esprit quand il a
besoin des pommiers clough l'or rose
désobéit ainsi par des aubépines et
parfumée dépeint ainsi riant de son pays
natal du chant du rossignol et du rouge
dodge ils ne s'adaptent pas au climat
tropical
cdi repenti repentir c'est en partie
parce qu'ils ne supportent pas l'esclave
âge là mes yeux ne seront plus
attristées du spectacle la servitude des
oreilles n'entendront plus le bruit des
chevaux et des ânes chaîne je ne devrais
plus ni tir en esclave je retrouverai
mon semblable mais malgré cette tirade
plutôt anti esclavagiste augusto logis
est bien l'homme de surtemps quand ils
ne voient pas la lys lannoy sont
semblables c'est à dire un être humain
comme lui dans sa 2ème net écrit le 31
août 1841 il répète des idées reçues sur
l'infériorité du noir africain qui n'a
pas de besoins qui ne pensent qu'à
satisfaire à ces primaires et qui ne
peut plus en recevoir des coups et la
pauvre les coups de fouet ou dropt est
distribuée pour les grandes folles et le
coche de coucher au blanc a toutefois
très cher comme les cela n'a qu'une
ambition vivre libres il ne peut nourrir
un quelconque
et croire en des lendemains meilleurs
quand on te laisse kabbaj a pas été
abolie augustin l'objet de blagues parce
qu'il n'est pas dans une dynamique de
projet
j'aurais quand même ce qu'il dit c'est
donc tout un peuple indienne ne sera
heureux que quand elle obligera passe
l'avait quand il sera dans une cave
enfumée à couper près de son foyer avec
son cochon et saint paul pour tout
meuble il ne lui faut qu une marmite une
calebasse et une hache pour couper le
bois le nail ne connaît que le besoin
physique il ne s'agit il ne s'imagine
pas qu'il existe d'autres bonheurs que
celui de boire manger dormir et danser
il n'a jamais prouvé ni inquiétude ni
chagrin pour lui le présent et tout est
sûr et certain que le lendemain il va
perdre la tête qui ne dormirai pas moins
bien son intelligence et décemment borné
et on peut dire qu'il n'a que l'instinct
nécessaires pour pourvoir à ses besoins
je maintiens une hutte se défendre
contre ses ennemis et voler avec de
telle région les punitions corporelles
sont indispensables lors de
l'apprentissage du catéchisme si chaque
soin les petits noirs et les noirs
créole finissent par obtenir quelques
mots les caf semble rien comprendre
qu'en retient rien du tout il explique
cette différence par l'absence de
religion de nos pays de départ et ne
vient pas à l'esprit de mettre en cause
la méthode d'apprentissage employés
répétition puisqu'ils ne savent ni lire
ni écrire qui exige une grande
concentration peu la fatigue de la
journée de travail dans leur pays n'ont
qu'une espèce de religion je crois même
que la plupart n'ont aucune idée de dieu
lapointe ce qui m'a fallu m adresser un
grand nom mais le fait beaucoup de
questions pour parvenir à savoir comment
il s'appelle que dans le langage ce
n'est que dernièrement je peux avoir
savoir que dieu en cave se déroule au
boulodrome à
tous les noirs d'afrique et de
madagascar sont rebaptisés et ce n'est
qu'à la tique de la mort qu'on leur
administre sacrement qui de recueillir
en état de santé parce qu'il le regarde
comme narrer de monde c'est le restera
une option
lesca abcd n'a droit à aucune cérémonie
à l'église
informations qu'ils offrent selon dont
sont particulièrement attrayants
qu'elles sont presque unique en loge
on voit sur notons quelques petites
croix de bois qui porte le nom sans
autre épitaphe
peu grave pas gravée sur c'est quoi des
mots troupe indépendants 1 de noah nommé
janvier venant de pnc cydia sa fille
âgée de 20 ans me briat décret à son nom
sur une croix je me prêtait volontiers
allure en ce triste service et après le
nom sa fille
j'écrivis ses mots
condamné en naissant au joug de
l'esclavagé
est lui longtemps j'ai mis dans ce monde
pervers
effets de la douleur un autre
apprentissage
si la mort à 20 ans avaient brisé c'est
faire comme le mois ne résiste pas le
jeu du temps aucun vestige
n'existe
comme l'idée n'était qui transperce
7,80 la gare était appréciée il a été
dans l'obligation de les effacer il est
triste dit-il de vie dans un pays où un
blanc n'ose pas prononcer tout haut le
mot de liberté dans la crainte que son
esclave ne l'entendent et ne vienne à le
comprendre cette confidence sur la tombe
des esclaves est unique en son genre
icade mène cette deuxième lettre en
justifiant son désir de repartir en
france
non plus pas l'existence du système
esclavagiste
mais pas les difficultés à gérer
l'esclave africain esclaves africains
essaient brut si grossier si apathiques
ci portait une mauvaise volonté qu'il
faut pour l'euro conduit une patience
angélique que le sien m'a certainement
refusé
lille saigne accueillante a été souillé
par la pratique de l'esclavagé les
bénéficiaires tiennent à sa perpétuation
auguste loger ne crois pas que
l'abolition soit possible est imminente
même si les débats au conseil coloniale
est à la presse sur les différents
projets envoyés par le gouvernement
central pour assouplir le système pour
que le compte à rebours et bien commencé
au final cette source fait ressentir la
complexité du système esclavagiste et
discrédite la lecture binaire qui a
longtemps prévalu
n effet à des récits des voyageurs ben
laden saint pierre
exodus elle l'a volé 11 de frayssinet
des administrateurs augusto milliards
des médecins charles morisod des
romanciers lui tu imagines wazzani
d'ailleurs gustav heinemann merck co et
berthe est connue et exploitée justice
ce nouvel essai épistolier apporte des
informations inédites sur la pratique de
l'esclavagé les bois bon en s'appuyant
sur ses propres expériences et ses
propres enquêtes orales pendant son
court passage dans cette île il pose
clairement le problème de la
transformation des faits historiques
lorsqu'ils sont véhiculés oralement en
offrant deux exemples inattendue
l'application du premier décret
d'abolition de l'esclavagé dont nous
fêtons le 227e anniversaire cette année
2021 et l'affranchissement de jean-louis
par le botaniste bénédictins joseph
hubert dont nous commémorons le 230ème
anniversaire
il vaut aussi pour ses révélations sur
le parler des esclaves africains ainsi
que sur le rapport des esclaves en
nature leur intégration au cosmos qui
l'europe des ressources pour définir des
stratégies lorsqu'il s'agit d'organiser
leur survie même ce discours est parfois
ambigu il conseillé il constitue une
source très utile pour étoffer la
connaissance historique sur cette
période de l'histoire qui mérite d'être
encore défraîchi jumeaux naissent votre
attention
[Applaudissements]